[موسيقى]
عندما تسمع هذه الإيقاعات، قد لا
تكون دبي هي المكان الأول الذي يتبادر إلى ذهنك،
ولكن على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية، احتضنت المدينة
مشهد موسيقى الهيب هوب المزدهر حيث
يمكن للمواهب أن تزدهر،
فهي واحدة من تلك الأشياء التي كانت هناك
هواية  وأصبحت مهنة
مصطفى إسماعيل المعروف أيضًا باسم مغني هيب هوب مقيم في الإمارات العربية المتحدة، وقد
انطلقت مسيرته بعد أن
حقق مليون مشاهدة في الفيديو الموسيقي الخاص به "
ولا كلمة" في عام 2020. لم أكن
أعتقد حقًا أنه سيصل إلى هذا الحد،
لم أفعل ذلك  "لم أكن أعرف حقًا أي شيء عنه
حتى أخبرني صديقي أنك أصبحت
رائجًا على تويتر، لقد كان أول نوع
من مقاطع الفيديو سريعة الانتشار بالنسبة لي، وهذا الفيديو يمنحك
دفعة أخرى، لذا فمن المدهش أن
موسيقى الغريب تتأثر بشدة
بمجتمعه المحلي، فهناك ثقافة
هنا  قصة لنرويها للأشخاص مثلي
الذين نشأوا هنا ويريدون سماع
قصة طفل نشأ في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
أو دبي ليرتبطوا بها، أعني أن هذا هو
جوهر موسيقى الهيب هوب مع
الكلمات العربية وإيقاعات الهيب هوب  أصبحت الموسيقى الغريبة
جزءًا من هذا المشهد الموسيقي الواعد،
فهناك الكثير من المعجبين وهم في
الواقع معجبون بهذا النوع من الموسيقى
وخاصة الحفلات العربية بشكل عام،
وأعتقد أن كل مدينة لها صوتها الخاص،
ولكل بلد صوته الخاص
ونحن مختلفون عنه.  الشعبية
تلهم المواهب الشابة لاتباع الدعاوى التي
أعرفها منذ أن كان عمري 12 أو
13 عامًا تقريبًا وما زلت من عشاق المعجبين
بالتأكيد مهدت الطريق للكثير منا
بما فيهم أنا وموسيقاه التي تعرفها
تتحدث إلى الشباب هنا و  بالنسبة
للجيل الجديد من الفنانين
يكتسب شعبية في المنطقة، فإن هناك
موسيقيين محليين آخرين يحدثون أيضًا
تأثيرًا كبيرًا على المشهد الموسيقي،
ويؤكد كريستوفر أن
هناك تاريخًا طويلًا عندما يتعلق الأمر بموسيقى
الراب والموسيقى المحلية هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.
أعتقد أن الشيء الرئيسي على الرغم من ذلك هو أنه
لم يكن هناك مركز ولم تكن هناك
مجتمعات ولم تكن هناك
حفلات موسيقية تحتفل بهذه
الموهبة، بل كانت في الواقع مجرد
ضجيج محلي أعطى الفنان نوعًا
من التعرض لهذا 20  كريستوفر البالغ من العمر عامًا
والذي أسس Rap dxb، وهو
مجتمع يجمع الفنانين معًا
لتكوين موسيقى الراب، XP هو محور يلتف
XP عبارة عن منصة وهو مكان
يحبه الفنانون الذين يحبون المواهب المحلية، لقد قمنا للتو
بإسقاط الإصدار الأول من ألبوم Rap the
XP  الهدف من هذا الألبوم هو
توحيد الثقافة وتنمية
المجتمع بدءًا من منصات مثل موسيقى الراب dxp إلى
المهرجانات الموسيقية إلى شركات التسجيل المحلية،
وهذه مجرد بداية
لمشهد الهيب هوب المزدهر في دبي، مشهد الهيب هوب
في دبي ينمو  لقد قطعت
شوطا طويلا إذا رأيت مشهد الهيب هوب في
دبي قبل 10 سنوات والآن هناك
فرق كبير بل سيصبح أكثر
جنونا لذلك
أنا متحمس